okay could i get some water please thank  you so much whenever you're ready i just  i want to be remembered as a good boy  you know look i didn't want to get my  paws into this it's a messy situation  but i feel like i have to clear my name  at the dog park the other day i  overheard a poodle say that i pooped in  johnny's bed like give me a break this  is ridiculous it's ridiculous sorry  sorry sit sorry look i'm six and a half  pounds and i saw the size of that stuff  it that ain't coming out of me when dogs  hear that you've been [ __ ] in  people's beds  you know it's it's game over for you in  this industry oh and what is your  industry barking at the amazon delivery  guy  sorry i've been trying to quit look i do  my business in the yard and occasionally  when no one else is home sure i'll do it  in the living room occasionally  who hasn't okay i think we're done thank  you so much uh treat treat  treat do you have a treat treat treat